stackdriver is a great platform that
lets developers and operators measure
and improve service reliability
however collecting a lot of data will
make it hard to find the information you
need and you may be paying too much
today we'll get into understanding and
managing your logging and monitoring
costs this is the stock doctor over the
last two episodes we reviewed using open
census and Prometheus tab custom metric
instrumentation - your services but what
is that going to mean for your cloud
spend let's start by reviewing how
stackdriver monitoring is priced this is
the current pricing but make sure to
check the pricing page link below for
up-to-date information the first thing
to understand is that monitoring is
charged by the volume of data required
to store monitoring metrics that aren't
generated by GCP services
this means that metrics from the
monitoring agent or custom metrics sent
by instrumentation like open census or
Prometheus will result in charges the
second thing to understand is how to
translate metrics to volume the key to
that is to use a rough rule of thumb to
treat a single time series data point as
8 bytes of data so if we sample a single
time series every minute for a month
that'll generate about 1/3 of a megabyte
of data you will then be charged based
on a total volume of data collected for
all of the metrics that are being
collected in the project now that we
understand how monitoring is priced we
need to see how much data we're actually
ingesting and storing and we can do that
in two places in the billing console and
in stackdriver itself first let's start
with the billing console you can access
it from the cloud console by going to
the products menu selecting billing and
then go into reports from there you can
search through just the costs associated
with the stock driver monitoring and
narrow are the reports of the projects
you are responsible for managing this is
a great way to understand your
historical usage in costs you can also
see usage information in the stack
driver a workspace by going to the
workspace settings and selecting usage
details here you can see exactly how
much metric data is being ingested from
every project that it being monitored by
the workspace finally metrics that show
how much monitoring data is being
Justin are available in stackdriver
itself you can use them to do things
like create dashboards and alert an
unexpected spikes and monitoring data
now you know where your monitoring costs
are coming from but what can you do to
actually manage that volume or even
reduce it the first thing to look at may
be your custom metric instrumentation
frameworks like open census and
Prometheus generate a lot of metrics
when you first start using them you may
not need all that information for
example the node exporter will provide
the same information you were getting
from GE node monitoring review the work
you've done to add custom metrics to
your service and determine whether all
of them are really necessary the second
thing you should review is your use of
labels the way that you use labels for
GCP components might impact the volume
of time series that are generated for
your metrics and monitoring for example
you can use labels on your VMs to
appropriately report metrics to cost
centers on your GCP bill and to signify
whether this piece of specific GCP
environments or production or
development but adding these labels
means that additional time series are
generated in monitoring if you label
your virtual machines with cost center
and environment very values then you can
calculate the total number of time
series by multiplying the cardinality of
both labels so if there are 11 costs
enter values and 5 environment values
that means that 55 time series are
generated this is why the way that you
add labels might ask significant metric
volume and therefore increase the cost
of course labels are helpful when you're
looking to organize your resources but
you mean be able to reduce your
complexity and cost finally you can look
at your monitoring agent configuration
metrics sent from the monitoring agent
are chargeable metrics the monitoring
agent streams application and system
metrics from common third-party
applications and additional GCP virtual
machine level metrics if you don't need
the detail assistant metrics or metrics
from the third-party apps for certain
virtual machines you can reduce the
volume by not sending these metrics you
can also reduce the metric volumes by
reducing number of VMS using the
monitoring agent now that we've covered
how to understand and manage your
monitoring costs let's move on to
logging let's review logging pricing the
model here is very straightforward
you are charged based on them I'm not a
volume data ingest
in the project over the free threshold
you should know that unlike monitoring
where some metrics do not incur any
charges all logs ingested incur charges
next let's move on to reviewing and
logging charges as with monitoring this
information is available in the billing
console the cloud console and in stock
driver itself in the billing console you
can filter the data to just report on
stackdriver logging to understand the
exact cost being generated by each
project to better understand why a
particular project might be generating
higher logging charges you can see
detailed information under log ingestion
in the logging menu this view provides a
service level breakdown of exactly where
the logging charges in your project are
coming from to get even more detailed
information you can select the view and
metrics explore for any row to get a
historical view of how these resources
were generating log data over time you
can then use this view to create charts
and dashboards to easily access this
information in the future now that you
understand how to capture measure and
analyze your logging costs let's dive
into some options for managing them our
primary mechanism to control lock
ingestion is log exclusions they allow
you to either broadly or precisely
specify exactly which logs will or will
not make it into stackdriver logging and
be available in the log viewer however
you should remember the logs aren't just
discarded when they're excluded you
still have the option of configuring log
exports to have them be sent to cloud
storage for archival bigquery for
analysis or pub/sub for delivery to
subscribers even if they're subject to
exclusions exclusions and exports work
together letting you choose which large
you want to keep for real-time
visibility and which logs you want to
archive without incurring logging costs
the more complex your applications and
the more monitoring and logging you'll
need knowing how these are priced and
how they can be configured can help you
manage the resulting costs thank you for
joining me today and come back soon for
more this is the stack doctor stay
healthy out there
[Music]
you
[Music]